MADELINE SCHMIDT: Good
evening, everyone.
My name is Madeline Schmidt.
I am a junior rhetoric
major at Hillsdale College.
And it is my absolute pleasure
to introduce Mr. Roger Kimball
this evening.
Roger Kimball is
editor and publisher
of The New Criterion and
president and publisher
of Encounter Books,
a contributor
to numerous publications,
including the Epic Times,
the Sunday Telegraph,
the American Spectator,
and American Greatness.
Mr. Kimball is editor,
co-editor, or author
of numerous books, including
Athwart History, Half a Century
of Polemics, Animadversions,
and Illuminations,
A William F. Buckley Jr.
Omnibus, The Long March,
How the Cultural
Revolution of the 1960s
Changed America, Vox
Populi, The Perils
and Promises of Populism, and
most recently, Who Rules?,
Sovereignty,
Nationalism, and the Fate
of Freedom in the 21st Century.
Will everyone please welcome me
in joining Mr. Roger Kimball.
[APPLAUSE]
ROGER KIMBALL:
Thank you, Maddie.
I thought you were going to say
something about my fabulous bow
tie.
Well, it's a pleasure
to be back at Hillsdale,
a little oasis of sanity.
Well, since this conference
is about the liberal arts
and education today, and my
own slice of that pie concerns
freedom and education, I'd
like to begin with a question.
And it's one that
I'd like you to keep
in mind as the evening unfolds.
The question is
this, what is liberal
about a liberal education?
Now that question is not as easy
to answer as you might think.
For one thing,
really to answer it,
you have to know what
the word liberal means.
Can you think of
any word that has
accumulated more conflicting
meanings than the word liberal?
And then there's
the word education,
who wants to give
that one a try?
In my experience, the more you
think about those simple words,
the more elusive
are their meanings.
In the materials distributed
for this conference,
there is a cheery quotation
from James Madison,
co-author of the
Federalist Papers
and a principal author
of the US Constitution.
Madison says that liberty
and learning belong together.
They support each
other, he says,
and further, their connection
supports a free society.
In various forms, the nexus
between liberty and learning
is a very traditional
idea, one that
has epistemological
and existential as well
as political dimensions.
Aristotle begins the
book we call Metaphysics
with the observation that all
men, by nature, desire to know.
Aristotle thought that
learning freed us,
gave us liberty from
the snares of ignorance,
illusion, and mere appearance.
Learning, he thought, not only
depends upon, but also begets
certain freedoms.
In the Gospel,
according to St. John,
Jesus says that you
shall know the truth,
and the truth
shall set you free.
In the Gospel, the relevant
freedom is freedom from sin.
But that point can
be generalized,
which is why various schools
and colleges have adopted
the saying as their motto.
And it's perhaps worth
noting that the CIA liked
the quotation so
much that they had
it etched into a wall
of their headquarters.
It's amusing to speculate
what the author of that saying
would make of this spooky
application of his words.
The Greek word that the
evangelist John uses for truth
is aletheia--
aletheia.
Interestingly, it
has a negative form--
a, letheia.
Etymologically, it
means not forgetful.
In Greek mythology,
the River Lethe
is a fount of forgetfulness.
Truth-- aletheia-- is
the antidote to lethe.
Memory, in other
words, is deeply
implicated in the
career of truth.
So let's come back
to the question,
what is liberal about a
liberal arts education?
As Professor [? Copps ?]
reminded us this afternoon
in his excellent
talk, the word liberal
comes from the Latin word
liber, which means free.
The original reason that
a liberal arts education
was so prized was because
it promised to free students
from the rust of prejudice
and presentism, the belief
that the present moment
is the summit of wisdom
and enlightenment, and that,
accordingly, the past is
nothing more than a graveyard
of discredited and mostly
malignant ideas.
Is liberal education still
liberal in that sense?
I'd wager that
everyone in this room
knows George
Santayana's observation
that he who is ignorant of the
past is destined to repeat it.
That is one reason we put
such stock by education.
We believe that,
when successful,
education can help rescue us
from making the same mistakes
that earlier
generations had made.
When I ponder the
recent itinerary
of education in this country--
and not just college education,
but the whole shebang--
I often think of that
old advertisement
for a brand of
cigarettes designed
to appeal especially to women.
You've come a long way, baby.
How right they were.
But a distance traveled is not
necessarily a progress logged.
It was not so long ago that
Cardinal Newman's enumeration
of the goals of a
liberal education
could have been taken as a
motto by the American academic
establishment.
Newman said that the chief
objects of a university
education were-- and I quote--
"a cultivated intellect,
a delicate taste,
a candid, equitable,
dispassionate mind,
a noble and courteous bearing
in the conduct of life."
That educational ambition was
quite normal in the 1850s,
but today?
Or consider the observation made
by the philosopher John Searle,
that, quote, "the idea that the
curriculum should be converted
to any partisan
purposes is a perversion
of the ideal of a university.
The attempt to
convert the curriculum
into an instrument of social
transformation," he said,
"whether it be leftist,
rightist, centrist,
or whatever, is the very
opposite of higher education."
Until the day before
yesterday, Searle's warning
was regarded as common sense.
Now it is uncommon and
highly provocative wisdom.
How easy it is to
forget the journey that
led us into this situation.
Now I'm not suggesting
that in the past
our educational
institutions always
lived up perfectly to the
ideal that Newman enunciated,
or that they always avoided
the perversion against which
Professor Searle warned,
but they aspired to.
Indeed, until at least
the middle 1960s,
there was robust agreement
about the intellectual and moral
goals of a liberal
arts education,
even if those goals seemed
difficult to achieve.
There was, for example,
a shared commitment
to the ideal of disinterested
scholarship devoted
to the preservation and
transmission of knowledge,
which meant the preservation and
transmission of a civilization
pursued in a community free
from ideological intimidation.
If we inevitably fell
short of the ideal,
the ideal nevertheless
continued to command respect
and to exert a
guiding influence.
The truth is that despite
widespread concern
about the fate of
higher education
and despite many
and various efforts
to call attention and remedy it,
the reality is, in many ways,
far graver today than it
was in the 1970s and 1980s
when exotic phenomena,
such as Afrocentrism,
post-colonial studies, queer
theory, critical legal studies,
and the attack on science by
anti-humanistic humanists,
was just beginning
to gather steam.
And despite the rise
of alternative voices
here and there--
and since I'm at Hillsdale,
let me stress the word here--
those dominating the
discussion at most institutions
are committed to discrediting
the traditional humanistic
ideals of liberal education
by injecting politics
into the heart of the
educational enterprise.
Consider the phenomenon-- the
phenomena of multiculturalism
and political correctness.
And I always think of putting
scare quotes around the word
multiculturalism,
because, really, it
is a form of monocultural
animus directed
against the dominant culture.
The multiculturalists
claim to be fostering
a progressive cultural
cosmopolitanism
distinguished by superior
sensitivity to the downtrodden
and dispossessed.
In fact, they
encourage an orgy of
self-flagellating
liberal guilt as impotent
as it is insatiable.
Hence, the woke sensitivity
of the multiculturalist
is an index not of
moral refinement
but of moral vacuousness.
Multiculturalism is a
paralyzing intoxicant.
Its thrill centers around the
emotion of superior virtue.
Its hangover subsists
on a diet of ignorance
and blighted good intentions.
The crucial thing to understand
about multiculturalism
is that not withstanding its
emancipationist rhetoric,
it is not about recognizing
the general cultural diversity
or encouraging pluralism.
It is about undermining
the priority
of Western liberal values
in our educational system
and, indeed, in our
society at large.
In essence, as the political
scientist Samuel Huntington
pointed out,
multiculturalism is, quote,
"anti-European civilization.
It is basically,"
said Huntington,
"an anti-Western ideology."
Now the most ironical aspect
of this whole spectacle
is that what appears
to its adherents
as bravely anti-Western is,
in fact, a part of the West's
long tradition of self-scrutiny.
Indeed, criticism of the West
has been a prominent ingredient
in the West's
self-understanding,
at least since Socrates
invited his fellow Athenians
to debate with him about
the nature of the good life.
No civilization in history
has been as consistently
self-critical as the West.
In attacking Western
civilization,
the multiculturalist is also
attacking the liberating spirit
of self-scrutiny, replacing
it with fashionable dogmas
of indoctrination.
Anti-Americanism occupies
such a prominent place
on the agenda of
the culture wars,
precisely because the
traditional values
of American identity
articulated by the founders
and grounded in a commitment
to individual liberty,
limited government, and public
virtue are deeply at odds
with the radical,
decivilizing tenants
of the multiculturalist
enterprise
of political correctness.
A profound ignorance of
the milestones of American,
or indeed of any other culture,
is one predictable result.
The statistics have
become proverbial.
Huntington quotes
one poll showing
that while 90% of
Ivy League students
could identify Rosa
Parks, only 25%
could identify the author
of the words "government
of the people, by the
people, for the people."
Another survey revealed that 40%
of seniors at 55 top colleges
could not say within
half a century
when the Civil War was fought.
The erosion of shared memory is
such a potent tool of tyranny
because it dissolves those
links with the past that
give substance to liberty.
The founding father,
James Wilson,
was right when he
observed that, quote,
"law and liberty cannot
rationally become the object
of our love, unless they
first become the objects
of our knowledge.
We must know the past in order
to profit from its lessons."
It almost goes without saying
that the tenured, or soon
to be tenured, radicals
now controlling nearly all
of the most prestigious
humanities departments
in this country reply that
their critics have overstated
the case.
Really, they say,
there is nothing amiss.
Nothing has happened that need
concern parents, trustees,
alumni, government, or other
private funding sources.
On the issue of enforcing
politically correct behavior
on campus, for example, they
will assure you that the whole
thing has been overblown by
conservative journalists who do
not sufficiently admire
multiculturalism and cannot
appreciate that the free
exchange of ideas must
sometimes be curtailed for the
higher virtue of protecting
the feelings of
designated victim groups.
And the curriculum, they will
say, has not been politicized.
It has been merely
democratized, opened up
to reflect the differing
needs and standards
of groups and ideas hitherto
insufficiently represented
in the Academy.
The aim of such objections is
not to enlighten or persuade,
but to intimidate and
to pre-empt criticism.
The truth is that what
we are facing today
is nothing less
than the destruction
of the fundamental
premises that underlie
our conception both
of a liberal education
and of a liberal
democratic polity.
Respect for rationality and
the rights of the individual,
a commitment to the ideals
of disinterested criticism
and colorblind justice,
advancement according to merit,
not according to sex,
race, or ethnic origin,
these quintessentially
Western ideas
are bedrocks of our political as
well as our educational system.
And they are precisely
the ideas that
are now under attack by
progressive academics
intoxicated by the coercive
possibilities generated
by their
self-infatuating embrace
of political correctness.
Political correctness
also fosters an atmosphere
of intimidation and
encourages a slavish,
moral, and intellectual
conformity,
attacking the very basis for
the free exchange of ideas.
Even worse, it encourages a kind
of intellectual sentimentality
that makes it difficult to
acknowledge certain unpalatable
realities, the
reality, for example,
that not all cultures, or,
indeed, all individuals,
are equal in terms of
potential or accomplishment.
It insinuates that
dreadful lie in the soul
that Socrates warned
about in the Republic.
Politics, the late journalist
Andrew Breitbart once observed,
is downstream from culture.
In the United States, a
primary engine of culture
is the educational
establishment.
Since the late
1960s, it has been
anything but an ivory tower, a
quiet, semi-cloistered redoubt
deliberately subsisting at one
remove from partisan passions.
On the contrary, the educational
establishment in this country--
and this goes for primary and
secondary education as well
as for colleges--
has incorporated those
partisan passions
as part of its raison d'etre.
The chief question is this,
should our institutions
of higher education
be devoted primarily
to education of
citizens, or should they
be laboratories for social
and political experimentation?
Traditionally, a
liberal arts education
involved both character
formation and learning.
The goal was to produce
men and women who,
as Allan Bloom memorably put
it, had reflected thoughtfully
on the question of what is
man in relation to his highest
aspirations as opposed to
his low and common needs.
In recent decades, however,
colleges and universities
have more and more been home to
what the literary critic Lionel
Trilling called the adversary
culture of intellectuals.
The goal is rejection and
repudiation, not reflection.
Now the key issue,
I hasten to add,
is not partisan politics per
se, but rather the subordinating
of intellectual life
to non-intellectual,
that is to say
political imperatives.
Indeed, it is this
failure, a failure
to check the colonization
of intellectual life
by politics, that stands behind
and fuels the degradation
of liberal education.
The issue is less the
presence of bad politics
than the absence of non-politics
in the intellectual life
of the university.
Now what has happened to the
educational establishment
cannot be understood from
its cultural context,
that long march through the
institutions that the Italian
Marxist Antonio
Gramsci recommended,
and whose American liniments I
chronicled in my book The Long
March, How the Cultural
Revolution of the 1960s Changed
America.
The Age of Aquarius, I wrote
in that book's introduction,
did not end when the
last electric guitar
was unplugged at Woodstock.
It lives on in our values, and
our habits, and our tastes,
pleasures, and aspirations.
It lives on especially in
our emotional and cultural
institutions and in the degraded
pop culture that permeates
our lives like a corrosive fog.
We have been seeing the
results of this dissemination
everywhere-- in the media, in
the corporate boardrooms where
resolutions deploring
systemic racism
are touted by quivering,
virtue-signaling bureaucrats,
throughout the federal
government where workshops
on critical race
theory catechize
government workers about
the evils of whiteness
and the glories
of trans culture,
and just this past summer
on our city streets
where Antifa and the trained
Marxists of Black Lives Matter
rampaged under the protection
of the First Amendment
while endeavoring to destroy
the political culture that
underwrites such protections.
It is a great irony that the
free speech movement, which
began in 1964 in the tumult of
Berkeley, has over the years
mutated into something
close to the opposite,
a kind of anti-free
speech movement
that approaches opinions
with which it disagrees
by attempting to cancel them.
It is not at all uncommon
on our nation's campuses
to find academics decrying
academic freedom in the name
of a putatively higher virtue.
At many institutions,
liberal education
has mutated into
intolerant indoctrination.
A similar process of mutation
or reversal has been at work
throughout the so-called
liberal institutions of Western
society--
in the corporate boardrooms
no less than in the media,
government bureaucracies, and
such cultural institutions
as museums.
Indeed, the metastasis
of illiberal liberalism
beyond the protected
purlieus of academia
is one of the signal cultural
deformations of our time.
What it tokens is nothing less
than the potential eclipse
of that robust understanding
of liberal society
that has informed the
self-understanding
of the Anglosphere, at least
from the time of Runnymede
and the adoption of Magna Carta.
At its core stand the
ideals of free speech,
religious liberty, and
equality before the law.
The repudiation of such
values and the value
of limited government, which
is a political precondition
for the thriving
of those ideals,
has underwritten the
redefinition of liberalism
from the championship
of freedom to illiberal
politically correct conformity.
It's perhaps worth pausing
to remind ourselves
that free speech does
not exist in isolation.
It is part of a
constellation of freedoms
that include, for example,
freedom of conscience
and the freedom
implicit in the idea
that all men are
equal before the law.
Those freedoms are, or
were, bedrock principles
in the modern secular West.
But increasingly, they are
up for grabs in a situation
where dissent from orthodoxy
is met not with disagreement
but with efforts at
suppression, scapegoating,
and ostracism, the entire armory
of so-called cancel culture.
It is worth noting,
too, how many
new disciples of
intolerance begin
by proclaiming their
allegiance to freedom only
to redefine it out of existence.
Freedom of speech is one thing,
said one such campaigner,
but usage of your
freedom should not
be to offend others or
advocate hate speech
or provoke people to violence.
Note that little word but.
Freedom of speech
is one thing-- but.
But what?
A common marker in this debate
is the phrase hate speech.
We're supposed to say
yes to free speech
but deplore hate speech.
Speech, as one partisan
of this Milquetoast
version of free
speech put it, that
offends or insults in general.
Now of course, the law has long
had statutes against speech
that incites violence or
that imperils public order--
gratuitously crying fire in a
crowded theater, for example.
But the phrase hate speech
is like that other item
in the lexicon of
less leftist redress--
social justice.
It is a weapon masquerading
as a moral imperative.
The adjective is
cognitively vacuous
but emotionally charged.
It injects an intoxicating dose
of moral self-righteousness
that clouds the head, even if
it sets the heart aflutter.
Now the large issue
here is one that
has bedeviled liberal
societies ever
since there were
liberal societies.
Namely, that in attempting to
create the maximally tolerant
society, we also
give scope to those
who would prefer to create the
maximally intolerant society.
It's the old Leninist
credo in action.
Demand freedom, toleration, and
diversity when out of power.
Practice suppression,
control, and the elimination
of opponents when in power.
It's a curious phenomenon.
Liberalism implies openness
to other points of view, even,
it would seem, to those
points of view whose success
would destroy liberalism.
Extending tolerance to
those points of view
is a prescription for suicide.
But intolerance betrays
the fundamental premise
of liberalism, namely openness.
As Robert Frost once
put it, a liberal
is someone who refuses to take
his own part in an argument.
The escape from this
disease of liberalism
lies in understanding that
tolerance and openness must
be limited by positive values
if they are not to be vacuous.
American democracy,
for example, affords
its citizens great
latitude, but great latitude
is not synonymous with the
proposition that anything goes.
Allan Bloom put it
well, "the fact,"
he wrote in The Closing
of the American Mind,
"that there have been different
opinions about good and bad
in different times
and places in no way
proves that none is true
or superior to others."
Our society, like every
society, is founded
on particular positive values--
the rule of law,
for example, respect
for the individual,
religious freedom,
the separation of
church and state.
Or think of that robust
liberalism expressed
by Sir Charles Napier, the
British commander in India
in the early 19th century,
told that immolating widows
on the funeral pyres
of their husbands
was a cherished local custom.
Napier said, very well,
we also have a custom.
When men burn a woman alive, we
tie a rope around their necks
and we hang them.
Build your funeral pyre.
Beside it, my carpenters
will build a gallows.
You may follow your custom,
then we will follow ours.
The point is that the openness
that liberal society rightly
cherishes is not a vacuous
openness to all points of view.
It is not value neutral.
It need not--
indeed, it cannot--
say yes to all comers--
to the Islamofascist, who,
after all, has his point of view
just as much as the
soccer mom, who has hers.
Western democratic
society is rooted
in a particular vision
of what Aristotle
called the good for man.
The question is-- the question
is, do we, as a society, still
have confidence in the
animating values of that vision?
Do we possess the requisite
will to defend them?
Or was the French philosopher
Jean-Francois Revel
right when he said that
"democratic civilization is
the first in history to blame
itself because another power
is trying to destroy it."
The jury is still out
on these questions,
and how they are answered
will determine the future
not only of Western
universities,
but also of that astonishing,
spiritual, political experiment
that is Western
democratic liberalism.
That liberalism is
embodied in the virtues
of disinterestedness
and impartiality,
the unbiased
discernment of truth.
It is symbolized, for example,
by the statue of justice
adorning our
courthouses, blindfolded
and holding a scale to declare
her allegiance to law, not men.
It is implicit in Martin
Luther King Jr.'s observation
that what matters is not
the color of your skin
but the content
of your character.
The entire premise
of Black Lives Matter
is antithetical to the
aspirations of equality
in King's hopeful sense.
Indeed, with its angry codicil
that asserting all lives matter
is racist, and
therefore impermissible.
The BLM movement is an
inversion of King's message,
just as it is an affront to
the ideal of impartiality
on which the rule
of law depends.
But the attack on that ideal
long predates the BLM movement.
It is woven deeply into the
culture of repudiation that
fueled the radicalism
of the 1960s
and undermined the
humanistic tradition
that, once upon a time,
our universities existed
to foster and hand down.
The cultural critic,
Christopher Lasch,
diagnosed it with great clarity.
"A misplaced
compassion," Lasch wrote
in his posthumously published
book The Revolt of the Elites,
"degrades both the victims, who
are reduced to objects of pity,
and their would be
benefactors, who find it easier
to pity their fellow
citizens than to hold them up
to impersonal standards,
attainment of which
would entitle them to respect."
Lasch, an old fashioned
liberal, understood
that embracing democracy
does not entail
a debasement of standards.
Equality, rightly
understood, requires
a respect for impartial
canons of achievement.
This insight lay at the center
of Matthew Arnold's Culture
and Anarchy.
"Culture," as
Arnold regarded it,
"does not try to teach down to
the level of inferior classes.
It seeks to do
away with classes,
to make the best that has been
thought and known in the world
current everywhere.
Hence, it is," Arnold wrote,
"that the men of culture
are the true
apostles of equality.
The great men of
culture are those
who have had a
passion for diffusing,
for making prevail, for
caring from one end of society
to the other the best knowledge,
the best ideas of their time."
Today, of course, the
contention that some ideas
are better than
others, let alone
that some deserve to
be called the best,
is rejected as an elitist
crime against diversity.
The cult or the
ideology of diversity,
what we have baptized as
identity politics, which
represents the systematic
rejection of everything
connected with impartiality and
objective impersonal standards,
is the enabling presupposition
of the destructive cauldron
of racialist obsession in which
our society is now marinating.
The irony is that our
current intolerance
is the perverted progeny of
the primary liberal value
of openness.
"It used to be," to quote
Allan Bloom one last time,
"that openness was
the virtue that
permitted us to seek the
good by using reason.
It now means
accepting everything
and denying reasons power.
The unrestrained and thoughtless
pursuit of openness,"
he concludes, "has rendered
openness meaningless."
If you doubt this, you could
tune in to the evening news
and listen to fancy
people explain
why destroying someone
else's property
is not violence, while
keeping one's own counsel
and refusing to join
in the mob and ritual
origins of denunciation and
self-abasement is violence.
A couple of concluding
observations.
In his book Notes Towards the
Definition of Culture, T.S.
Eliot noted that, quote,
"culture is the one thing we
cannot deliberately aim at.
It is the product of a variety
of more or less harmonious
activities, each pursued
for its own sake."
For its own sake--
that is one simple idea that
is everywhere in peril today.
When we plant a garden, it is
bootless to strive directly
for camellias.
They are the natural product
of our care, nurture, and time.
We can manage it, still,
when it comes to agriculture.
When we turn our hands
to cultura animi,
to the cultivation
of the soul, we
seem to be considerably
less successful.
Let me end by noting that
the opposite of conservatism
or conservative is not
liberal but ephemeral.
Russell Kirk once observed
that he was conservative
because he was liberal, that
is committed to freedom.
Kirk's formulation
may sound paradoxical,
but it touches on a great truth.
To be conservative,
that means wanting
to conserve what
is worth preserving
from the ravages of time and
ideology, evil and stupidity,
so that freedom may thrive.
In some plump eras, the task
is so easy we can almost
forget how necessary it is.
At other times, the
enemies of civilization
transform the task of
preserving our culture
into a battle for survival.
And that, I believe-- and
I say it regretfully--
is where we are today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm happy to entertain comments,
questions, and [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER 3: Yes.
Thank you, Mr. Kimball.
Mr. Kimball has agreed to
sign copies of his book,
Who Rules?, Sovereignty,
Nationalism,
and the Fate of Freedom
in the 21st Century,
following this session on
the second floor of Searle.
We now have some time
for a Q&A, please
make your way down the aisle
if you have a question.
AUDIENCE: So I've noticed a lot
of schools similar to Hillsdale
have a very small student body,
while the schools that maybe
advocate for some of these
degenerative educational
practices have a really
high student body.
And I was wondering if
there's a way we can prevent
the masses from having
such a poor education
if schools like this are very,
very few and far between.
ROGER KIMBALL: I would say that
Hillsdale is-- can everyone
hear me?
Do I need to get back--
SPEAKER 4: There are
people watching online,
so you got to go get your mic.
ROGER KIMBALL: OK, great.
I would say that Hillsdale
is unique, not just unusual.
But unfortunately, it's worse
than your question suggests
because many of the
very worst Petri dishes
incubating this disease
are small schools.
All of the top--
all, I believe, all
of the so-called top liberal
arts, fancy schools, especially
in the East for
some reason, they
may have a student body
of a couple thousand,
or a few thousand.
They're small.
They're expensive.
They have too much money.
But they are assiduous
in promulgating
all of the worst aspects
of this cultural revolution
that I intimated.
They're just as bad
as the huge schools.
And in fact, worse,
because the large schools,
while they may be intellectually
less distinguished,
are, in many cases, given
over to other pursuits.
They're not really concerned
with liberal arts education,
although they may say so when
they send out their fundraising
letters and so on.
But they're really concerned
about, in many cases--
not in all, but in many cases--
as a kind of vocational
education, which is fine.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But they're not really
part of the effort
to pass on this liberal
tradition I was talking about.
So I think it's not just
a matter of numbers,
it's really a matter of quality.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
coming, Mr. Kimball.
I think I started reading
The New Criterion,
and my father would
earmark it for me, probably
by the time I was 14 or so.
And I don't know,
has anybody ever--
maybe it's the bow tie.
I think you bear
some resemblance
to Duncan Stroik,
the chapel architect.
I don't know, did
anybody else notice that?
ROGER KIMBALL:
Actually, he's my twin.
AUDIENCE: Makes sense.
I just wanted to ask,
you mentioned that for--
it's not the idea
that education ought
to be free from
ideological bent itself
and ideological
or philosophical,
if you will forgive the
equivocation, proposition
when considered in the
context of a modern state.
So I say the modern
state in contrast
to the ancient or
medieval regimes,
which did not have the power to
be so all-encompassing in terms
of state or government
involvement in education.
So for example, today,
Hillsdale's independence
from government seems to imply
an ideological bent, when
ideally it wouldn't, right?
ROGER KIMBALL: Well,
every society, and indeed
every common pursuit,
depends upon an affirmation
of certain values.
And there is a sense in which
that affirmation is political.
But when it comes to
liberal education,
the political affirmation
turns importantly on the idea
that none of us has a
monopoly on the truth.
And therefore, it
is a good thing
to foster a community
where people
can follow the
argument according
to their own best lights and
talk about it with other people
and debate it.
That is not a
political activity,
although it depends
upon a previous decision
that being able to engage
in that kind of free debate
is a worthwhile thing to do.
So when people say,
well, Hillsdale
is just as politicized as
Yale or Williams or something
because their decision to be
free from government intrusion
is a political act.
And there's some truth to that.
But where that
falls down, I think,
is in failing to recognize that
by essentially taking yourself
out of the influence
of people who
want to rule the way in
which you conduct yourselves,
you have not become slaves to
somebody else but are free.
So it seems to me that it's--
you often see people make
this rhetorical move.
They'll say, well, isn't
that just as political
as being non-political?
And you saw this, for
example, in the phrase--
I alluded to it, although
I don't think I quoted it--
this summer people would
say silence is violence.
But no it isn't,
violence is violence.
Silence is silence.
And the metabolism
of this phenomenon
that you're talking
about is something
that it's very important
to be alert to because it's
used not in good faith, but
it's used as a sort of bludgeon
to try to make it impossible to
pursue a genuinely liberal arts
education, and beyond
that, to pursue
a genuinely liberal society,
where people live together
because they affirm certain
basic values about the nature
of their society but are
otherwise free to pursue
their lives and to
disagree and engage
in public, spirited debate.
We are in a situation now, not
just in our educational lives
but in the life of this country,
where dissent is regarded
as a kind of criminal act.
And it's instead of--
it's sort of like heresy.
And down that path is a
very, very dangerous end.
I think we still have time
to step back from the abyss,
but we are close to the abyss.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for your talk.
So there were two sides here.
We have diversity
and multiculturalism,
which I don't think are
necessarily inherently bad,
but they do have to be
balanced with preserving
a homogeneous national culture
necessary to sustain a country.
So there's a tension there.
How much nuance
would you introduce
into that conversation?
ROGER KIMBALL: If I
understood your question
it's, multiculturalism
is not necessarily bad
because it provides
diversity and that sort of--
well, the problem
is that what goes
under the name of
multiculturalism
is there's no multi about it.
It really is a kind
of, as I said--
I think I've said-- of
a monocultural passion.
So if you actually
look at what is
being taught as multicultural.
You'll find that really it's
just a series of cliches.
The people who are promulgating
it don't know, for example,
other languages.
If you really wanted
to be multicultural,
you would learn the languages
of these other cultures
that you were pretending
to talk about.
But no, it's really--
it's a kind of fancy,
polysyllabic form
of monocultural
passion, at least
that's how I have
experienced it whenever I've
looked into the way
in which it's actually
promulgated on campuses.
It's taught not as a way of
learning about other cultures,
but as a way of undermining
Western culture.
It's all cultures are
equal, except they're all
superior to the West.
It's a version of what Orwell
talked about in Animal Farm.
All cultures are--
all animals are equal,
but some are more
equal than others.
SPEAKER 3: Question
to the speaker's left.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for being
here, Mr. Kimball.
This speaks to the question
that was just asked.
But in your speech
you discussed how
multiculturalism
and pluralism have
corrosive effects
on our education
and our society at large.
But I was wondering, is there
a seed of good or something
valuable in these ideas?
And in other words, what
does the non-Western world
have to teach us?
ROGER KIMBALL: Well,
the non-Western world
might have a lot to teach us.
But it's been my
experience, first
of all, that what goes under
the banner of multiculturalism
actually doesn't
really learn very much
about the non-Western world.
And secondly, it seems to
me that, as Americans, we
want to be able to affirm who we
are first before pretending to,
A, criticize our society
and, B, adopt as if we are
a vacationing other cultures.
I think if you
actually look at what
is taught in colleges under
the banner of multiculturalism,
you'll find that most often
it's composed very largely
of anti-Western
animus rather than
genuine intellectual curiosity
about other cultures.
That said, I think it's
important to understand that--
I think I mentioned
this just in passing--
that all cultures
really are not equal.
And Saul Bellow got
into a lot of trouble
when he asked, where's
the Tolstoy of the Zulus?
People didn't like that.
But that is not an illegitimate
question, it seems to me.
Now there might be.
There might be a great
novelist of the Zulus.
I don't know.
But it's important to be able
to tell the truth about things
and to call things
by their real names.
And I think that there's
a great sentimentality
among some Americans about
the virtues of other cultures
that the more you look at them,
the less justified that seems.
A novelist who was very
brilliant, I think,
and brutal about exposing
that was V.S. Naipaul,
who, himself, was from Trinidad,
I think, and really understood
a lot about other
cultures, but he also
understood the toxic
effects of sentimentalizing
those cultures, especially
for people from the West.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming on tonight.
This relates to an
earlier question,
so I apologize for
repeating anything here.
But one thing you
mentioned was how
the apolitical has
become politicized
and the intellectual,
political is entering into it.
And I was just wondering if you
could speak a little more what
do we do about this.
So for example, a book like
Huckleberry Finn, which
could be put in a
great books curriculum,
it's now become a
political statement
to put it in the
curriculum in a way
that it wasn't not too long ago.
So is there a way we have to
depoliticize the apolitical,
or is it too late for that?
What can we do to recover just
reading Huck Finn because it's
a great book, and for no other
political aim other than that.
ROGER KIMBALL: Yeah, I think
that's a very good question.
What we can do is say, quite
frankly, to the people who say,
we're offended by Huckleberry
Finn, or "Othello,"
or teaching Chaucer, who's,
after all, a dead white guy--
some famous college
has just taken
Chaucer out of its curriculum--
is to say no.
We are going to--
the fact that you're
offended offends me.
And so we're not going to
submit to this politically
correct effort at intimidation.
Instead, we are going
to look to the past
for the criterion of literary,
artistic, cultural achievement.
Why?
Well, David Hume said,
what is a work of genius?
And he said, it's
durable appreciation,
those works that have been
appreciated for a long time.
And of course, now that
phenomenon changes.
Things go in and out of fashion.
In the middle of
the 19th century,
people like Shelley and Byron
thought Tasso was terrific.
Very few people
read Tasso anymore.
There was a time
when Walter Scott
was thought to be top dog
when it came to novelists.
I think Scott is not really
read that much anymore.
But the point is, these
matters of taste, I think,
should be determined
by impartial standards.
I mean, taste is an
interesting thing, isn't it?
It's pretty clear, Immanuel
Kant pointed this out
in his Critique of Judgment.
There's different
kinds of taste.
You might like your steak well
done, I might like mine rare.
That's a kind of
aesthetic judgment,
and aesthetic meaning
having to do with sensation.
But we understand that
this sort of taste
that's involved in
literary judgment
is something different.
And what is
different about that?
Well, Kant has
his little schema.
Actually, it's not
so little, but he
has a way of explaining that.
But it's to basically appeal
to a larger community.
And he says that aesthetic
judgment, in that sense,
has an ennobling and
enlarging effect.
Well, that's obviously a
hint of a long discussion.
Why is it, you might ask?
Why do we think that works
of art are important?
Clearly we do because we
spend millions and millions
and millions of dollars
building museums and acquiring
works of art.
Why do we think
education is important?
Again, clearly we do.
I mean, there are 4,500
institutions of education--
higher education
in this country.
So we think that there's
something important about it,
even if, to some
very large extent,
we've lost sight of that.
But it seems to me that
the most important loss
is exactly what
you're talking about,
being able to judge these
works on their own terms.
That's why I mentioned
toward the end
that you do something
for its own sake.
It's not for some ulterior
utilitarian motive.
It's because it's
a good work of art.
And again, there's always going
to be discussion, disagreement
about that.
But that's what makes
life interesting,
that kind of disagreement.
To have someone say, no, you
can't read this because it has
words I don't approve of in it.
That's not on, I would say.
SPEAKER 3: Thank
you, Mr Kimball.
We have time for
one final question.
AUDIENCE: Hello, thank you
for your comments tonight.
My question is related to the
religious language you used,
specifically with some of the
opponents of liberal education.
And with that
level of commitment
to their ideas and
devaluation of reason
in dialogue, what do you see,
or what do you prescribe,
as a means to combat
that for people
that would adhere to reason
as being the superior
means to go about these issues?
ROGER KIMBALL: Let's make
sure I understand you.
Are you opposing reason
to religion, or--
AUDIENCE: No.
So when you were speaking of
some of the contemporary ideas,
you used language like
baptized and things like that.
And I think rightly, there is
a religious element of this.
But in that, they've
devalued reason
in a way that makes
it hard for people
that are liberals
in another sense
to use reason to combat it.
So what would you
prescribe for a means
to combat something that
is religious in nature
and antithetical
to using reason?
ROGER KIMBALL: OK, so the cult?
Yeah, well, I
think, first of all,
the first step is
recognizing what something is
and calling it by its
real name, as I just
said to the last chap.
There's a book by a man
named Norman Cohn called
the Pursuit of the Millennium.
And it's all about these
medieval movements,
the brotherhood of the
free spirit, people
who felt that they
had somehow achieved
a higher level of virtue
than the other people
in their society.
And this enabled them to
do all kinds of things.
They were not bound anymore
by the normal morality
of the people who
were not enlightened.
They could do
whatever they want,
because they occupied a
higher plane of enlightenment
and a direct connection, so
they thought, with the Godhead.
They might say
that all material--
the whole material
world is evil,
except, since I understand
that, I'm no longer bound
by the normal codes of morality.
If that sounds a lot like
what happened in the 1960s,
you're quite right.
That's also what
happened, by the way,
in the French Revolution.
Why was it?
Why was it that Robespierre,
the disciple of Jean-Jacques
Rousseau, why was it that
the word virtue was always
on his lips?
He took that word and that
concept from Rousseau,
and the idea being
that he wanted
to create a virtuous society.
Society was not virtuous,
Robespierre thought,
so we have to get rid
of certain people--
the people who are virtuous
in my sense, said Robespierre.
They have to be gotten rid of.
So the index of virtue
for the French Revolution
was the rapidity with which
the guillotine got rid
of those who were not virtuous.
It's a poisonous idea.
And again, you don't have to
look very far in our society
to see that kind of
sentiment at work.
If you pay attention to the
rhetoric of Black Lives Matter,
for example, or Antifa,
or certain members
of that large
building in Washington
that's now surrounded by a
12 foot fence and razor wire,
you hear scary echoes
of that kind of thing.
They're virtuous,
and you're not.
And they believe that
with a religious fervor
which does not invite
conversation or disagreement.
But like any heresy,
it invites condemnation
and being stamped out.
Thanks.
SPEAKER 3: Thank
you, Mr. Kimball.